[Musique]
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui en ce
dimanche on est nationale de
commémoration des mémoires de la traite
de l'esclavage et de leurs abolitions
pour récompenser les lauréats nationaux
de la session 2021-2022 du concours la
flamme de l'égalité
assisté à une cérémonie et récupérer les
prix qu'on a gagné on a participé on a
créé un projet qui raconte toutes
l'histoire de l'esclavage la dureté la
vie des esclaves des tout-petits qui
travaillaient dans les champs dans les
canne à sucre et tout c'est
impressionnant se dire que nous à notre
âge en fait il travaille déjà
[Musique]
on travaillait des mois et des mois avec
leur professeur ils ont découvert une
histoire qui connaissait un peu
l'histoire de la traite de l'esclavage
je peux vous dire qu'après tout ce
travail scolaire ils sont transformés
ils sont plus riches et ils sont surtout
plus lucides parce qu'ils connaissent
notre histoire et puis sont plus forts
pour affronter les défis du temps
présent
arrivera dans les années qui viennent
répondent aux défis immenses de la
connaissance de la transmission et de
l'unité face à tous les risques de
fragmentation
[Musique]
très bien le gouvernement de Paris que
les nouveaux livres n'accepteront jamais
de retourner en Islam
pensive que des hommes qui ont été à
même de jouir des bienfaits de la
liberté regardons calmement qu'on aille
leur avis
il y a un enjeu de mémoire bien entendu
avec cette commémoration nationale un
enjeu de reconnaissance la
reconnaissance des souffrances vécues
bien entendu par leurs esclaves la
reconnaissance aussi des
héritages qui sont des héritages
présents dans les sociétés comptabween
et auxquelles il faut s'attacher la
lutte contre toutes les formes de
racisme la lutte contre les
discriminations
[Musique]